all right let's get to a couple of other
um non-vaccine things that i wanted to
go over we're still dealing with
the aftermath in many different ways of
the january 6th trump riots and um there
is a really interesting exchange between
two members of congress that i want to
look at with you today one of them is a
member of congress you may not be
familiar with its democratic congressman
joseph morrell
from new york the other guy is someone
you probably would be familiar with it's
republican congressman jim jordan who
was one of the
members of congress trying to stand in
the way of the certification of the 2020
presidential election on january 6th and
who
there was an attempt made to put him on
the committee investigating the trump
riots when really he seems maybe more
like a witness
or even a co-conspirator in those events
but regardless he had a really
interesting exchange yesterday
at a hearing
meant to be about
voter
laws gerrymandering access to voting etc
and he
utilized a
rhetorical crutch
that a lot of these what i call
pseudo-insurrectionists
light insurrectionists have been using
when confronted with
we're now how many months out we're now
nine months out from the election
are you ready to say that joe biden
really won and they have this rhetorical
crutch they use where they say
i admit
joe biden is president
and of course that's a way to not really
answer the question so let's take a look
at it this is very interesting the gist
here is his talking point is not
actually an answer to the question okay
so let's jump right in if there's been
all this suppression that that that
previous democrats of the speakers have
talked about which isn't working very
well because we have record turnout
which is as we've said now multiple
times the ranking member said it i think
all of them
is so what he's arguing here is we don't
really need to do anything about voter
suppression because it clearly doesn't
exist because we had record turnout in
the election this is his line of
reasoning and then joe morrell cuts in
it's a good thing so of course that
hasn't happened it's a disgrace i also
find it curiouser and curiouser
that
mr jordan you would use 2020 data on
election participation when you won't
even acknowledge the outcome of the same
election right i've been knowledgeable
have you did joe biden win this election
there was no fraud you're prepared to
say that he's president united states
now that he's the president of the
united states and joe morrell points out
you're not answering my question jim
that's not what i asked you did he win
the election you said he's the president
of the united states that's only because
we were here while the capital was being
besieged by thousands of people
retention overturning stuck around to be
able to confirm the results of the
electoral college that's why you
acknowledge the president
all i've said is we should look into
concerns that lots of voters have i've
never said that he didn't win he's the
president united states but i said we
should look into the concerns i think
that's just common sense well looking at
concerns is fine i just the problem is
you guys don't have to i don't know how
many court cases we've asked for
investigation so this is this is
important to understand this is a tool
that is used really often it's a
rhetorical tool that's used in general
which is you're asked a question
where
the real answer that's the substantive
answer would be politically
disadvantageous or it might be
disadvantageous to the point you're
trying to make
so you answer it but you're not really
answering it substantively you're
responding but you're not answering it
substantively
there's a classic example of this that i
want to play for you guys this is any
opportunity i have to play this i take
because it's just such a great example
this is back in the bush era
a former deputy assistant attorney
general john yu
was being asked by congressman john
conyers
is there anything a president couldn't
order done to a prisoner
bearing the prisoner alive
whatever and john you i i've actually
used this in the class i taught john you
answers every other question other than
the one being asked so let's look at
this together this is it's really worth
understanding this rhetorical crutch
because it's used so often here we go
is there anything miss professor you
that the president could not order to be
done to a suspect
if he believed it necessary for national
defense
well
mr chairman i think that goes back to
the quote you just read because no i'm
just asking you the question maybe it
does it doesn't but what do you think i
think it's the same question that i was
asked well what's the answer
first can i can i make clear i'm not
talking about and you don't have to make
anything clear just answer the question
council so this by the way this is all
the build up this is not actually using
that crutch but he will
i just want to make sure i'm not saying
anything you don't have to worry about
not saying just answer the question okay
my my thinking right now yes right now
okay my thinking right now this moment
yes this this moment mr chairman
is that uh
you know first
the question you're posing what is the
answer
mr i'm not trying to make you uh i get
it okay let me answer the ques i will
answer that no you you've wasted you're
wasting my time look council
practice law hold it
could the president
order a suspect buried alive
mr chairman i don't think that i have
ever
i'm asking you that given the advice
that the president could bury something
so so remember
this is at the heart of
what can we do what what counts as
torture what's not this is this was a
major issue at the time if this was
before you were following politics this
was a issue of paramount importance
and the question was
if if the president said
bury this suspect alive
could they legally do that and john you
says i've never given a president that
advice that's that but that's not the
question somebody alive i didn't ask you
if you ever gave him advice i asked you
do you think the president could order a
suspect buried alive mr chairman my view
right now is that i don't think a
president would no american president
would ever have to order that or feel it
necessary
[Laughter]
that's again not actually answering the
question that is being asked uh going
from i've never given that advice
to i don't think a president would ever
feel it necessary to do that but the
question is
if the president felt it necessary to do
that would it be a legal thing to do so
jim jordan doing the same thing many
republicans when they're asked did joe
biden win fair and square they say joe
biden is the president we know joe
biden's the president he was sworn in
it's another way to get around having to
actually substantively answer these
questions
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most innovative
shower head it uses only about half the
water that other shower heads do saving
you money helping the environment but
it's actually a lot more powerful than
other shower heads on the market it has
twice the coverage of other shower heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up really easy and it's been a
totally different experience than any
other shower head i've used i can get in
and out of the shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off so i was actually amazed that
it's only using about half as much water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match perfectly with the design of
the shower head the shower head starts
at just 199 and you'll get 10 percent
off all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video